lining the roots of Nicola's last known
movements exactly a week on from when
the mum of two disappeared close friends
and even those who don't know her came
out in force in search of answers
including Nicholas partner Paul speaking
publicly for the first time he said he's
been living in Perpetual hell I just
can't believe that that we can't
and as yet
it seems like we're no further on it's
just just seems
it just seemed absolutely impossible
every single scenario
comes to a brick wall every single one
of them and then all we're doing is
sitting there going around around going
through every scenario and then go back
to the first scenario again his girls
know their mummy is missing and are
waiting for her to come home my whole
focus is my two girls
just staying as strong as I can for them
I'm scared that if I put any focus into
anything else
it's going to take my you know Focus off
that
it is as though
she had vanished into thinner like
yeah just here him just insane
and as the days go on police say their
concerns for Nicholas whereabouts
increase extensive searches haven't yet
Unearthed any evidence an unprecedented
number of search resources have been
been searching the river and the bank
this includes drone
the helicopter
police divers
sonar equipment
pole cameras
underwater drone
this is included the area where Nicola
went missing and the 15 kilometers or so
down to the Sea
unfortunately we have not still found
Nicola
but our search does continue
investigators believe there is no one
else involved in her disappearance or
any signs of criminal activity so what
happened to this missing dog walker
police have narrowed down a 10-minute
window in which Nicola was unaccounted
for it was in that short space of time
she disappeared they believe she did not
leave this area and now their
investigation is based on the theory she
fell in to a very deep and Cold River
for Nicholas friends who've been
searching day in and day out it's been a
brutal week police said that their main
theory is that they believe Nikki may
have
fallen into that River how did that make
you feel as I said I I guess
yeah it was
if you let your mind go there then I
don't know how you come back from it
this quaint Village in rural Lancashire
has been hit with a tragic story amidst
all the mystery of this case One Thing
Remains clear hope is not in short
supply and Nicholas heartbroken family
still believe she'll be home soon into
man Rashid Sky News Lancashire